[Musica]
quando si parla di cambio climatico mi
piace ricordare qui dove stiamo noi
parlando 15 mila anni fa scendevano i
grandi ghiacciai dalle alpi e andavano a
sciogliersi in pianura padana
era un clima molto più freddo rispetto
ad oggi eravamo alla fine di un'era
glaciale e temperature erano più basse
probabilmente di 5 gradi perché è
cambiato così tanto perché la nostra
atmosfera è molto sensibile a piccoli
cambiamenti che possono essere portati
della radiazione solare o dalla giunta
di gas serra all'interno di essa è
quello che stiamo facendo in
quest'ultimo secolo dalla rivoluzione
industriale ad oggi abbiamo bruciato
carbone e petrolio producendo anidride
carbonica che è un gas serra e quindi le
temperature hanno cominciato ad alzarsi
su scala globale
l'aumento delle temperature ormai
raggiunto un grado
ti chiamo ad accorgersi del cambio
climatico sulle prealpi qui il clima
gradevole e temperato e possiamo
tollerare dai cambi di temperatura senza
accorgersene particolarmente per questo
dobbiamo rivolgerci allo studio di serie
climatiche raccolte per esempio fin
dagli anni sessanta dal centro geofisico
prealpino
all'interno di queste sere che il primo
parametro che possano guardare e quanto
aumenta la temperatura media nel corso
degli anni ci accorgiamo che dagli anni
60 ad oggi la temperatura è già
aumentata di 2,2 gradi
questo aumento delle temperature non è
omogeneo e funzione delle stagioni è
molto più marcato durante l'estate e
durante la primavera mentre invece lo è
meno in inverno il mese che sia più
scaldato è il mese di giugno che ha già
raggiunto un aumento di 4 gradi ma anche
i mesi di maggio giugno luglio e agosto
hanno raggiunto dei riscaldamenti
attorno ai 3 gradi
questo riscaldamento ha persino ormai
cambiato la percezione che noi abbiamo
delle stagioni quando usiamo è
l'aggettivo primaverile
spesso ci riferiamo a un clima ormai
gradevole e soleggiato mentre invece la
primavera un tempo qua a varese era
fresca e piovosa anche ormai il tempo
val d'agosto non rinfresca più il bosco
perché settembre è un mese ormai
pienamente estivo
il parametro che forse più di tutti ci
indica come è cambiata la temperatura
durante l'estate è il numero di giornate
che superano la soglia psicologica dei
30 gradi
un tempo queste giornate erano
praticamente sconosciute a varese
avrebbero meritato fino agli anni
ottanta un titolone sui giornali oggi ne
registriamo una quarantina per ogni anno
con delle punte addirittura di 50 sono
quelle che chiamiamo le ondate di calore
che sono così poco sopportabili in città
dove al calore dell'aria si aggiunge il
calore che restituiscono gli edifici e
le strade sulle prealpi ancora
sopportabili molto e meno sulla pianura
padana dove il calore e anche più
intenso questo probabilmente nei
prossimi decenni potrebbe addirittura
spingere le persone che abitano in
pianura a trasferirsi stagionalmente
sulle prealpi alla ricerca di un po di
frescura
certamente bisogna lavorare su questo
per mitigare il clima delle nostre città
il modo probabilmente più semplice
naturale è quello di aggiungere aree
verdi l'evapotraspirazione dalle foglie
degli alberi aiuta raffrescare la
temperatura l'evaporazione di un solo
grammo di acqua produce un
raffrescamento di circa 2 gradi e mezzo
di un metro cubo di aria
dall'altra parte rispetto alla pianura
delle prealpi abbiamo le alpi anche
sulle alpi cambio climatico si fa
sentire in maniera veramente importante
l'aspetto principale è la scomparsa dei
ghiacciai la scomparsa di ghiacciai sarà
praticamente completa ormai è
catastrofica entro qualche decennio non
soltanto sarà una perdita paesaggistica
ma ci sarà porterà una modifica
importante del regime idrico che abbiamo
nei nostri fiumi e nei nostri laghi
mancherà dunque la cadi fusione dei
ghiacciai e quindi una diminuzione di
portata dei nostri fiumi soprattutto nel
periodo estivo quando avremo più bisogno
dell'acqua per l'irrigazione
le piogge oltretutto saranno più brevi
ed intense e quindi ancora una volta ci
troveremo confrontati al problema di
avere tanta acqua quando piove e poca
acqua invece nei periodi siccitosi anche
il mediterraneo sta diventando sempre
più caldo e diventerà quasi un golfo del
messico per la
la penisola italiana portando eventi
meteorologici importanti intensi ancora
una volta con piogge e brevi e
concentrate del tempo
tutto questo farà sì che dobbiamo
imparare proprio qua nel terra
dell'insubria tra i laghi dove non
abbiamo mai avuto problemi di
risparmiare l'acqua dovrebbe imparare
invece a gestirla ea risparmiarla
se gli attori climatici della stagione
estiva sono tutto sommato abbastanza
chiari l'inverno è una stagione più
complicata da interpretare
all'interno dell'inverno molte influenze
meteorologiche fanno la loro parte e
quindi tutte le stagioni fredde sono un
po diverse le une dalle altre
abbiamo come d'estate l'invadenza
dell'anticiclone che ci porta a lunghi
periodi di siccità e con inversioni
termiche e la stagnazione nell'atmosfera
con aumento degli inquinanti al suolo
poi abbiamo le perturbazioni autunnali e
primaverili che si spingono ben addentro
nei mesi invernali portando le loro
piogge abbondanti
il dicembre e in gennaio e infine il
riscaldamento del polo nord con
diminuzione della forza dell'aria fredda
al polo che tende a scendere e di tanto
in tanto a latitudini più basse
queste brevi discese d'aria fredda non
contestano però la diminuzione della
nevosità che osserviamo ormai in maniera
importante a partire dagli anni 70 sulla
montagna varesina a 1200 metri fino a e
le grandi nevicate degli anni 80 85 86
misuravamo 4 metri di neve fresca
negli ultimi decenni ormai siamo passati
a 180 cm anche in città la diminuzione
della nevosità e importante avendo
praticamente è diminuito la mancanza di
neve durante l'inverno porterà a un
aumento del rischio di incendio infatti
i boschi di latifoglie sul sottobosco
sono ricchi di foglie secche e quando
queste non sono coperte dalla neve
ovviamente è più facile appiccare gli
incendi
aumentano le temperature anche nella
stagione invernale non così tanto come
d'estate mediamente di un grado
aumentano di 2 gradi le massime con
belle giornate gradevoli però le notti
stellate portano a una stazionarietà
delle temperature minime
comunque sono diminuiti le giornate di
gelo e questo ha una influenza molto
importante sugli ecosistemi la mancanza
del gelo invernale influisce per esempio
sulle popolazioni degli insetti che non
vengono uccisi dall inverno e quindi
proliferano durante la primavera
moltissime delle nostre foreste di
conifere della
nelle prealpi sono state infatti
distrutte da invasioni di insetti anche
altri ecosistemi e risentono fortemente
degli più miti e più brevi ad esempio
tutti gli animali che effettuano
migrazioni preferiscono adattarsi a un
inverno più mite rispetto ad affrontare
il pericolo della migrazione la
primavera d'altra parte diventa sempre
più precoce abbiamo visto come le
temperature in primavera stanno
aumentando rapidamente quelle
temperature che un tempo misuravamo alla
metà di aprile
ormai le misuriamo a fine marzo questo
ci porta a delle sorprese botaniche come
per esempio quest'anno abbiamo avuto la
fiorire della mimosa per san valentino e
noi normalmente come accadde verso fine
marzo il clima quindi sta cambiando qui
e ora non siamo più solo spettatori di
quello che avviene in posti lontani al
polo nord o in amazzonia
la prospettiva che tra 50 anni le
temperature aumenteranno in una
forchetta compresa tra 1 e 5 gradi
se in grado sono ancora temperature
sostenibili 5 gradi saranno
catastrofiche per gli ecosistemi e per
il nostro benessere
qui termina il ruolo del metereologo
cosa possiamo fare abbiamo due direzioni
nelle quali muoverci una e la
mitigazione quindi individuare le
direzioni del cambiamento e prepararci a
questo cambiamento
alcuni esempi li abbiamo fatti per
esempio a portare il verde in città
oppure risparmiare l'acqua e poi secondo
più importante ridurre le emissioni di
gas serra
questo si può fare sostenendo politiche
e prodotti che siano più rispettosi
delle risorse naturali e ci portino
rapidamente a una transizione energetica
verso fonti più pulite
[Musica]